everyday citizens and businesses
generate prosperity across Europe by
selling their services and products
across borders or working in another
member state citizens move and travel
from one member state to another setting
up home taking a new job building a new
life the European Commission wants to
ensure that the principles of free
movement and equal treatment for EU
citizens becomes a reality in people's
everyday lives to raise awareness of the
rights and opportunities offered by the
European single market the European
Union launched a new award the single
market award for the first time ever a
single market award will be handed out
this award has been established by the
Swedish presidency and the European
Commission the single market award is
given to a person or organization who
has worked actively to help people
benefit from the European single market
the winner of the first single market
award is Aurora to fry touch a
Portuguese woman living in France since
nineteen sixty eight and the winner is
mrs. Aurora de Freitas
mrs. de frottage worked as a seamstress
and a stylist for many years and is now
retired she won the award for her work
helping Portuguese citizens prove their
resident status in France JD vocalism
swaddles excellent irme de la maladie
Ultron travail pour le persone erev pro
premier from France on sweet gem sativa
too poorly carted seizure pass credit
references a partir de milk at evilly
pop resonate deeper me Caesar without
their French residence permit Portuguese
citizens living in France are left with
only their Portuguese identity card
since this car does not carry the
holders address it is difficult for them
to pay by check open a bank account or
prove their address when stopped by the
police sufjan shake rosencrantz and
Khujo owned Adam Adam Adam opposite on
TT is low do nae comme le t perera me LM
less ipanema okay d in suitably jealousy
2wd who see party salia spotty a pass
from New villosa come on D zoopla rama
rama pass give near the control or even
near Lugh patron even eaten moon in
Mercia Tara mom back seat reached uma he
passed him gives a motorbike accident ET
pour together he assesses aha here dr.
Sara yes you may be plugging directly
personally silica d sigma sigma
Christian woman yes no more large ID
sustainable to the reader a donkey I'm
addressing a desert original color de
Zarate drama o + a on six men Allah
Commission europeana a prepper Oh
sweetie sucks i see stay loose on soviet
air x of it oh na boku boku problem
solver is a network for EU countries
work together to solve problems caused
by the misapplication of european law
citizens and businesses can turn to
solve it for free fast and practical
help when like mrs de frottage they are
denied their single market rights
there's a solvent center in every
European Union member state and in
Iceland legends
and Norway
me paro en Armando mala la novela de
todo será una di porta plant grass
Madame de Freitas cansado nella
coordinate solve it un apartamento
colossal it is really vais avoir de
cartas Sergio definitive una Casa Azul
vidya Madame agua de Freitas
to suny new film noir up fort je crois a
europe